We've just launched our MCP integration
with Word Rocket. So, now you can
connect Word Rocket to any of your
favorite tool. One of the biggest use
cases now you can connect Word Rocket to
your favorite large language model like
Claude or Chat GPT. And in today's
video, I'll be showing you exactly how
to do so. So, first you want to head
over to docs and support. And then we're
going to head over to public API. And
then we're going to click MCP server.
Now, I'm going to make this a little bit
easier for you to access MCP right from
the Word Rocket
dashboard. But once you're in MCP
server, it'll walk you through how to
connect Word Rocket to your favorite AI
tools. Do note, you need to be on a
premium or an agency level plan in order
to get access to MCP because this is a
premium feature. Now, the easiest way to
connect to Claude or OpenAI Chat GPT is
by copying over this URL https
wordrocketapi.com.
So, I'm going to copy over this API. I'm
going to head back over to Claude.
And then I'm going to head over to my
profile settings.
Connectors.
We're going to click customize.
And here is now where we can add a
custom connector. So, connector we're
going to click add. We're going to click
a custom connector. I'm going to name it
Word Rocket.
And then we're going to paste in our
Word Rocket uh URL. Click add.
Then we have to click connect.
Just give it a few seconds. It's going
to authorize your MCP connection. So,
it's going to allow you to generate and
manage articles, run keyword research,
publish to WordPress, view usage, and so
on. So, it's going to ensure that that
you are uh sorry, that account that
you're on actually has
um MCP integrated. So, that's why you
need to be on the right plan.
So, if I head back over to Claude now,
we can see here that Word Rocket has
been added. Once it's connected, now we
just have to change our permission. So,
you can leave it so that Claude can do
whatever it like with the Word Rocket
integration, or you can tell it to
always ask you before it does something
with this integration. You know, this is
going to be important if you want to
have more control over when Claude uses
this integration.
So, now that we have the Word Rocket
integrated into Claude, everything that
we could do in Word Rocket, we can now
do it in Claude. So, for example, I
could tell Claude to write an article on
the most popular topic in the real
estate Toronto niche for today, include
3,000 words, two images, use the web
mode, and write for my specific client,
use their site map um for internal
linking, and post directly over to their
WordPress site when completed. Right?
So, essentially, again, what I'm doing
here is I'm combining Word Rocket with
Claude, so Claude can do some additional
research, and then send that information
over to Word Rocket. I could even tell
it to do its own research in Claude, and
send that over as additional
instructions, so that the article can be
even better. Right? So, once I go ahead
and I send this over, I am using the
cold work mode, but you can also use
this in the chat mode, and even use it
on the web app interface. It's going to
kick everything off, research Toronto
real estate trends, check your Word
Rocket account, and grab Brain Voice at
all at once. Right? So, you can see here
on the right-hand side, it's using the
Word Rocket connector that we just set
up, and it's also using the web search
mode. While this is writing, as you can
see, this opens up a lot of use cases
and opportunities for what now you can
do with Word Rocket using Claude. So,
you can actually use the schedule mode
to schedule this to happen every single
day for your specific niche. So,
articles are going to be researched,
written, and posted directly over to
your WordPress site using Claude and
Word Rocket.
So, as we can see here, it was able to
get everything. It got the client, the
site map, the WordPress, and it found a
topic, and I was generating the 3,000
word article. So, if I actually go over
back, and if I go under my content, I
should be able to see that article, and
we see the article here is being
generated.
So, we know for a fact that this is
working. So, just give it a few minutes
for it to continue.
If you go back over to connectors here,
we can see that there's also a lot of
other connectors in which you can use.
So, we see that there's a connector for
SimilarWeb, there's a connector for
Ahrefs, there's a connector for Canva,
there's a connector for HubSpot,
booking.com booking.com, so on and so
forth. So, whatever niche you're in, you
can find a new workflow that you can
create. For example, if you're, you
know, within the travel niche and you
write travel content, you can connect
Tripadvisor to then find you the most um
up-to-date trips for January of 2027,
and write an article about that. You
could use the HubSpot integration to
pull data that's relevant or analytics
that's relevant, and use that to then
write content for an internal meeting
or just to get an idea of different
analysis. So, you can see here that if
you go through connectors, there's a lot
of different connectors. There's
monday.com, there's booking.com, Zapier,
Asana as well. So, you can connect
really, really in-depth um workflows
using Claude and
Word Rocket together.
So, if we head back over, we can see
that the article is now completed. So,
3,000 words, a live web search, full
FAQs, SEO title, and meta description.
So, we can see that the full article has
been generated. So, we You our key
takeaways, we get our custom image, we
get our internal links as you can see
here. It's web research, it's in-depth,
it's a really, really good article. And
as you as you can see you get your
title, you made a description and your
tags. As you can see this is a super
powerful integration. Head over to
app.wordrocket.ai if you want to sign
up. You do need to get an agency or a
premium monthly plan, but as you can see
it's definitely worth it. If you have
any questions let me know in the
comments below. I'll see you in the next
video. Take care.